οναπλά οποίια δήποδε στιγμή θα πάω και εγώ στο σίτιαναάρθρόμου εγράψα ότι κπιι θεωρούν ότι
είναι αναγκαι ιτάγματος υπάρχουν κάποιο υπουργί η οποιη θεωρούν ότι χωρίς αυτού ε λιτουργά το
κράτος καικαθιοτίτι αυτή την άποψη η θεωρείται ότι υπάρχουν άτωμα τα οποία αδεν υπάρχουν στατμε
οποι εδώ και αρκετά χρόνια οι αρχ ι μό πρόγονι ουδήησαν αντικατάστατος είμαστε εδώ να
προσφέρουμε νόσο μπορούμε και όσον καιρόν είμαστε ν εδώ χρήσημηας αξιοποιήσουμε τούτον το χρόνο που
είμαστε εδώ σαν να μην υπάρχει αλλημέρα και αυτό θα το κρίνει ο κόσμος και
ο πρόεδρος φυσικά που είναι αυτός που απόφασηζιέρα θέλ να πω ότι το έχο δουλέψει
αρκετά μέσα μου είμαι εδώ για ένα συγκεκριμένο χρονικό διάστημα είναι προσωρινώ αυτό για ανα
δουλέψω να ηλοποιήσω το πρόγραμμα το οποίον έχον προστά ου και αυτό το πρόγραμμαα δε
με εξεφραζε δεν θα είμουν εδώ πιστεύω ότι κάπνοντας πέντεέξι πράγματα σοβαρά μπορούμε να αλλάξουμε
τα πράγατα στην παιδίά του τόπου μας πωθα καλοκαιρι για θα περάσουν να πόμε για
να έχουν όλα τα σχολία τληματιστικά το εργόμενο καλοκαιρι ίδη έχουν τόποθετηθεί κληματιστικά σχεδόν σεόλες
τις επαρχίες και πρέπει εδώ να το οπούμε νό ατι σηνώμε πουαλλι το ποθέτησήα τώρα
τίση να το ελινααθέση να πατήσουν το πουνμπι και να ζεστένονται ι να ιτοχίριο στοκαλοκαίρι
γιατα έχλο και θέρμας έχουν όλα θέρμαση και εντρική θέρμαση να πω ότι τελικά αυτό
το εχείρημα δεν είναι το σοναπλώ εγκατάσταση κληματιστικού είναι ένα νεχείρημα το οποίο περιλαμβάνει και
πλήρι να ανανέωση του δικτύου δυστυχώς του κάθε σχολείου το οποίο ν ερχεται μαζί με
την εγκατάσταση και αυτή ανανέωσι και αναδόμηση του δικτίου είνεται μια φοράευτυχώς και γίνεται τώρα
οπότε εκεί που εγκαθίστανται κληματιστικά γίνεται και η πλήρησα ναβάθμηση του ηλεκτρομή χανολογικού δικτίου του
σχολείου σε συνεργασία με την αρχήν ηλεκτρισμού